this program is brought to you by Emory
University
there should go for the test very
rapidly there should be tested everyone
should have the test for HIV because
it's the only way to get the benefits of
the treatment that we have in her hand
today and it's a bit the best way as
well to prevent other from the infection
in addition to the classical preventive
measure of course like condoms usage
like changes in behavior and so on they
are to be tested they have to go to the
test test is available it was very hard
in the past to encourage people to go
for testing when we did not have any
treatment today we have a treatment it's
not a cure but we know that the
treatment is bringing a lot of benefit
for the patients and is also a
preventive measure for the others
you
the preceding program is
by Emory University